turn your great idea into a reality with
Squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project
whether you are showcasing your work or
selling products of any kind with
beautiful templates and the ability to
customize just about anything you can
easily make a beautiful website all by
yourself but if you do get stuck
Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support is there to help
head to squarespace.com slash Grace for
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch it was the offer code graced your
AC to save 10% off your first purchase
of a website or domain
hey guys producer director Jack ferry
here with a little content warning this
episode has some mature content in it
specifically about recreational illegal
drug use in case that's something you
don't want to listen to or watch too
deep I'm very excited today as always
because we have a wonderful wonderful
human being she's an amazing comedian
amazing writer and all-around like my
awkward nervous shy soul sister Kate
Friedman is with us today she has
starred in and created the TV land
series teachers she's in a bunch of
other things happening right now and
she's worked at Victoria's Secret and
has basically talked to pervs frequently
so we're gonna get into all of that on
this episode of not too deep with Kay
Friedman Kate Friedman hi hi I'm so
excited that you're here I'm so excited
to be here thank you for having this is
a very thrilling episode and I want to
talk to you about teachers I want to
talk to you about the the show in the
Edinburgh Fringe Festival oh okay
because we were just talking that you
went to what was the music fest we just
went to just went to North Coast Music
Festival in my hometown of Chicago okay
and you're obsessed with Miguel yes I am
who I just learned about oh my gosh I'm
so happy you just learned about him and
I hope millions of other people also
yeah Kate networks for the gracias
Miguel promotion foundation I'm just
trying to get like a
free vape pens yeah he's like his own
line of vape I mean I've seen him I
follow his fiancee or maybe they already
got married I'm obsessed with her too
and she has one and it's like really
cool well you're manifesting yes and out
into the universe but you said they went
to this festival to relive your
Coachella experience yes tell me about
that
oh gosh I've never been to Coachella oh
boy and every year I think about going
especially because Beyonce was
headlining holy crap and I I chickened
out every year I don't know if I took it
out or I just like forget and then get
over it it looked incredible oh gosh I
wish you were there I hope you'll
consider coming next year okay how many
times have you gone I have only gone
once but I do deem myself an expert only
ones actually Coachella 2018 funnily
enough if that's a word was actually my
first real music festival oh really
yeah and since that date in late April I
am now I now just live to go to music
festivals okay what is it about them
that like converted you yeah absolutely
like I I don't know is it the magic of
music cuz it's like partying that I
missed out on in my teens in my early
20s because I was like straightedge for
so long not that you need to partake in
anything to enjoy Coachella because its
own thing but it was just you know I
obviously very excited about the lineup
Beyonce yeah challenge America I mean
the greatest and my best friend growing
up she also loved Eminem and he was
closing it out right you know we should
go I was kind of like having a module I
freaked out of like will I ever have
money again when go to Coachella and my
best friend at home she's the best her
name is autumn and she had just had this
like kind of like hard-ass year that was
just like brutal and I was like we need
to go and do something epic and
celebrate and you know we're both about
to turn 30
she's training through this fall on me
next year and I was just like we got to
do it up before we can't do it up
anymore this is my last chance so we got
we got the tickets and my friend was
like you did what and she was shocked
and we went for obviously all three days
and yeah amazing a lot was learned like
I think the beauty of the festival was
everyone getting together singing you
know cuz everything's so ass rotten
right now there's some glimmer of hope
when everyone's having a purely
wonderful time absolutely yes yes and
you know it sounded cheesy before but
then when I went and like you know
you've got strangers you know dancing a
space cowboy and like you know doing
some type of like weird ballroom dancing
and like greeting each other like this
like it was just like oh like I I
finally at 29 have found my people this
is this is my home what is the biggest I
guess lesson you learned or like piece
of advice you could give of like new
festival-goer you know like I'm kind of
embarrassed to talk about it but like I
will you know don't don't ever do malli
three days in a row oh that's a good
sound piece of advice do not do it and
then come down the calm down must be so
intense holy holy mother of God I am I I
mean like I like I'm kind of joking but
I'm also kind of dead serious when I say
like I am grateful to still be here in
the moment you're like I'm never coming
down exactly like I'll bounce back I'm
drinking so much water in vitamins I'm
having a few meals a day human survival
thing boy oh boy I guess maybe it was
also important to note that maybe it was
like my first time also doing Molly oh
so you went hard
I went hard
and it was really ignorant and like you
know like I you know um I a little as
someone who like researches like every
little thing wrong with them health-wise
or this was the one time I decided to
bypass Google and not feel like blindly
jumpin yeah why why why I don't know and
of course like Beyonce like that's the
most epic thing like oh my god I mean I
had never I did you watch it on YouTube
I watched some of it but I went to the
VMAs like a couple years ago when she
did like an abridged version of lemonade
for like 15 minutes and I felt like I
was on Molly yeah like it was so above
and beyond better than all the other
people that have been performing it was
so good that you're just like how how
does someone so good oh that like truly
I was left with that question is yeah
like I I mean both of us just jaws on
the floor like every every just every
just minute of that like I it was like
obviously like I'll i have no musical
talent even though like i wish i did for
like if we did like can you matt unstop
I'm freaking stoppable but like that I
felt like I was like I it was a you know
a master class and everything music all
that but like also in performance like I
had never like as like a theater and
comedy geek like oh my god like I had
never seen anything like that stage
presence holy crap in Destiny's Child
coming out like that way you and all the
aesthetic feels without a doubt like
when you're there with your best friend
like since kindergarten and like you
never think you get to like be like you
know up close and personal with the
songs that we sang like yesterday and it
was just like it was beautiful it was
truly aside from my ignorance and for
taking an illegal street drugs which
like again like you know I would be safe
by testing packets don't do it but I
think that's a very practical advice and
I think that that will be listeners and
Watchers out there that will be like no
dude don't you I was about to do
something terrible for myself that's
great okay let's talk about teachers
this was a big part of your life
absolutely because this we had Kathryn
Thomas on an episode a few weeks ago and
she was telling us all about it and it
sounds like such an insane wonderful
opportunity to have this a group of
women then get to create a TV show
together yes it was great it was a dream
come true it was crazy yeah how did you
guys all come together absolutely yeah I
started as a sketch and improv comedian
in Chicago and that's where I met the
rest of the group and we all the same
name and we thought it would be like ha
ha ha we're gonna do an improv show and
like this is so funny and we thought
it'd be a one-off but we had so much fun
and we kept going and going and going
and you know before you know it five six
years later were getting the you know
the craziest opportunity in the world
that's so not yeah so did you guys all
move to Los Angeles like together
collectively no that would have been
cool it was kind of a a few of us moved
out here earlier than the other half and
then as likes to things started to heat
up here everybody kind of came out so it
was like you know a little bit of space
but kind of behind at the same time
gotcha at the same time okay and your
character AJ yeah the description is
loves a snack and believe she would have
been in jail had she not become a
teenager how similar is real life to
this character painfully similar how did
you guys did you guys alright
your characters as kind of versions of
yourselves in a way okay yeah absolutely
we kind of when we sat down it started
as a web series okay yeah which is super
fun that we actually shot at the middle
school I actually attended really oh
yeah and baby better believe someone is
still to the teachers are still there oh
wow which was interesting no that's like
sweet or depressing oh my god I either
at first I was like oh this'll be sweet
like this is the moment where like it
all
comes together and there is this sum I
loved like reading and writing in school
but I and I still am you know like I'm
painfully shy and like awkward and like
it's you know I was never the one to
like raise my hand in class cuz it I was
so [ __ ] terrified yeah and there was
this one language arts teacher that
really picked on me and it was a middle
school is like that's not the time to do
that and everyone is firing on all
cylinders and everyone is nervous and
it's these are the times that the
memories will stick with you for the
rest of your life without a doubt I mean
these are the moments that shape us but
she went really hard on me and because I
was so quiet there was a disconnect for
her between like the papers I would send
in versus the person that she would get
in class and she called my mom she's a
Kate is a plagiarist and boy and I was
like oh god oh god yeah this is you were
a good student I was a good writer but
like I couldn't I couldn't prove it in
person right guys I I don't I don't know
it just it was very painful and scarring
for me anyway she was there when we
filmed the web series and I was like
this is my mom and I was like hey miss
like remember me and like the blankets
face she had no [ __ ] clue who I was
and I was like come on you know around
2003 I was in here like and I was like
well I guess I'm shooting a web series
now so it all worked out and she was
like she was oh is so her she's just
like mmm
I guess some of us just need more time
to blossom oh wow
cruel to the very end like wouldn't let
me like can we come together it's 20
whatever it was like you know I am kind
of an adult now yeah and I was like dang
she got me again back in your mind just
like middle school of everything you
could have said
absolutely absolutely that's so so nice
it was it was nuts well okay my question
for you about filming the TV show I am
always very nervous and uncomfortable
around children and you guys had so many
on set all the time it seemed like what
was that like for you um you know what
it I like the same way and was scared
but it having the kids around like
honestly it was like the best part
really they're so funny and sweet and
you know the beauty of being able to
shoot it in Los Angeles is that all
these kids are about 15 million times
more experienced there's like so there's
so much to learn I mean they're they're
freaking good like yeah in front of the
camera and they just go and you get to
learn a lot and also like I mean it
sounds creepy and weird but like having
some younger friends is cool man they
were like legitimately like very cool
and and I like I was definitely
intimidated at first but truly filming
with the kids and gosh some days there'd
be 60 70 80 kids of different ages it
was the it was the best part you know
hit up crafty and see like can anyone
teach me how to ride he leaves like
truly the loveliest part it was great
what's the fan base like for teachers do
you have people that stop you from the
show yeah have you had any weird
encounters in that realm at all I you
know I that would have been cool if I
did but like truly every encounter has
been like really lovely and like the
people who watch the show are like very
kind and supportive like any any little
run-ins um I met the nicest kid at North
Coast the other weeks like oh my god
you're feldman right I'm like yes I am
and you caught me at a music festival
which is perfect because yeah I guess I
ya know everyone lovely lovely lovely
like people I'm very afraid to fly
and it's embarrassing and I
white-knuckle it and I cry and I I truly
like there was a flight I was taking
from Denver back to here and it was the
worst weather ever like you know flight
attendants like straps oh yeah really
really bad and I got very very scared
and so I was like wailing I was like god
please I'll do better I'll do better I
get was at that and just like people
were like what the [ __ ] and then but
they were still calling they're like hey
like I love the shown as a yeah they've
they've been there for me that's awesome
yeah okay you directed Kimber Hall's
show yes and it's called I have always
been a storm yes how did that go
oh my gosh it was it was a very
meaningful and very cool experience yeah
what's the what's the concept of the
show absolutely it's this magical
wonderful kids show although both Kimber
and I think that adults can enjoy it too
and it follows this wonderful like fairy
like character named T who is a really
like it's truly like Kimber came up with
a brilliant show but this character T
who is a storm cloud that works at
weather systems incorporated well yes
and the clouds that work there are
separated into brute force clouds and
gale force clouds and T found that they
didn't fit in with either one of them so
it's a children's show encouraging
people to feel free to be themselves and
you know exploring the possibilities
beyond the binary for all of us really
but for kids too that's awesome yeah it
was really really awesome it's kind of
inspired by my dear friend Kimber a
their actual story coming out to their
family and all that kind of stuff so it
was really very very special that's
super cool is it happening anymore um
you know she gosh she did 30 days of the
show at fringe
which is an intense insane experience
sure I can't even I can't even imagine I
wanted to go so bad but yeah I mean it
just and scheduling-wise didn't work out
but um gosh I think he closed two weeks
ago and I we're hoping to do it in LA or
maybe turn it into like one of those
shows that would travel all around ya
know I'm from Chicago and Kimber is from
st. Louis and just like oh yeah Kimber
was really inspired to really do the
show because it's like the show that
they wish they could have seen when they
were a kid yeah and a thing yeah so like
the thought of like being able to tour
it I think is really enticing to us and
hopefully we'll be able to do that or at
least just have it in the way yeah well
I hope it works out it sounds incredible
and it sounds like something with such a
important message no I can pack it in a
way that is digestible for adults and
kids absolutely I love that okay we're
gonna take a super quick break and when
we get back I'm gonna ask you basically
more about Beyonce do that right after
this guess what grace I can probably
guess is it a Squarespace act that's
true Oh amazing
did you know I because I just wish for
it upon a star and a half of that I'm so
grateful for it
well they're our buddies and they want
you to know that you can turn your dream
into a reality with Squarespace wear a
space makes it easier than ever to
launch your passion project whether
you're looking to start a new business
showcase your work published content
sell products and more Squarespace is
the tool for you with beautiful
templates created by world-class
designers and the ability to customize
just about anything with a few clicks
you can easily make a beautiful website
all by yourself Squarespace is powerful
ecommerce functionality lets you sell
anything online and analytics help you
grow your site in real time everything
is optimized for mobile right out of the
box and there's nothing to patch or
upgrade ever amazing buying domains is
simple and you'll get the help you need
with Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support Squarespace empowers
millions of people from designers to
lawyers artists to gamers even
restaurants and gyms and JAC fairies
berry
yes I use Squarespace to turn great
ideas into something real and let me
tell you guys it really is easy to use
so get a shot
head to squarespace.com flush grace for
a free trial and when you are ready to
launch use the offer code grace grac e
to save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain that squarespace.com
slash grace offer code grace this
episode of not too deep is sponsored by
ModCloth at ModCloth there's no such
thing as an ordinary outfit crafted by a
team of in-house designers ModCloth
signature style include hand-drawn
prints standout silhouettes and an
inclusive size range that celebrates all
women falls in full swing at ModCloth if
you're not already curled up in a
sweater they've got you covered with
cozy essentials and cute knits that
won't quit and if you're feeling festive
be sure to check out their holiday gift
guide featuring unique finds and perfect
presents for everyone on your list
yourself included prep for those
upcoming holiday parties with mug cloths
party boutique discover everything from
sheer lace to luxe velvet to
irresistible Sparkle and if you got a
question about fit their team of mod
stylists can hook you up with
complimentary sizing and styling help
and guys I am a full advocate of
ModCloth I just recently got a maroonish
deep red sweater with a oh my god why am
i blanking hello neighbor
mr. Rogers mr. Rogers Thank You Jack for
being here - Jack check this I was too
excited about it but I totally forgot
that I got a mr. Rogers sweatshirt from
them they have everything that's like
cute and feminine - mr. Rogers it's up
to you and they have everything and you
guys get 15% off your purchase of $100
or more by going to ModCloth calm enter
code NTD at checkout
that's mo d CL o th comm and enter code
n TD at checkout for 15% off your
purchase of $100 or more this offer is
valid for one-time use only and expires
on January 5th 2019 yeah ok you're in a
movie all
Nina yes I am what tell me about this oh
man it's this really really cool script
from writer director Eve of Eve's okay
if I mispronounce a last name I'm gonna
be so humiliated she wrote this amazing
script and it's a little bit of her own
story and or quite a bit of her own
story actually which i think is so cool
and it's stars mary elizabeth winstead
who's the best yes so awesome
and I kind of chose this character is
experienced as a comedian stand-up
comedian and some you know going through
some really tough life yeah offstage
yeah absolutely
that's it sounds very cool it's it's
awesome I'm so excited for everyone to
see it I have a very small role in it I
play a very nervous stand-up comedian
named Maria who gets you know I won't
ruin it but it gets really nervous to
the max at their big audition I can't
wait it comes at the end of September I
believe it comes out at the end of
September by the time this goes up it
will be out hopefully we'll have seen it
and if you haven't go see go see it go
see it guys that's awesome
how was filming that experience it was
awesome it was it was so fun I was so
nervous because it was you know like I
felt like I was walking into something
where like everybody I'm like such a
huge fan of them like Nicole Byer was
one of the other comedians and I was
like and of course like she's the nicest
person ever and the coolest yeah
funniest oh my god she was like so she
made me feel totally at ease and had
kept me laughing the whole day just like
everybody else lots of great alaik me
and Jamie Loftus was like the comedy yet
she's so [ __ ] funny she was like the
comedy consultant so she was there the
whole time and she's awesome and drave
vermeuhlen was not common and coming
come on one of the greatest comedian
I've heard he's like the nicest man ever
you know I didn't get to meet him
but I hear he's pretty nice next time
next time that sounds awesome and that's
kind of an ideal role to play someone
that's nervous yeah yeah because that's
I mean that's my same role is to fly and
anxiety-ridden pursuing entertainment
persona yeah that's a dream it's not a
stretch for you or okay what's your
relationship with social media um social
media scares me I like it I I guess I
would consider myself like a lurker yeah
I was gonna say I always ask people
which we're all guilty of being workers
are there any accounts that you like
hate follow oh um you know like I'll I'm
sure there have to be some you know I
don't like anything like I I guess I
don't have any hate follows I am
unashamed to follow away okay so who's
like your top ones like what are you
looking at well I'm well here's the
other question to you I know you're
obsessed with Big Brother you know
that's exactly where I was
have you made the deep dive into
following those Instagram accounts yes
but I have to unfollow or mute them
because we live on the west coast and
mad spoilers spoilers yeah and they're
they're so brilliant like there's one in
particular that is my absolute favorite
and the name is Kaltura which is
actually a deep cut reference to maybe
five six seasons ago when there was like
a spelling competition and one amazing
contestant pow pow she's the she's a
legend she was trying to choose like I'm
gonna spell calculator and get all the
MF in points but she ran out of time and
she could only get Kaltura which like I
respect and appreciate it's like one of
my favorite Big Brother moments so this
account is called Kel Torrio and they do
these awesome like funny little memes
and these like beautiful edits of
certain players on the game which I like
legitimately like enjoy and I'm always
like oh hey guys have you seen this it's
really funny but it's okay would you
ever be on the show oh my god I don't
think I could hack it yes I just I don't
I like the biggest super fan but like
even like I I just I I think I'd be the
person like the first week that gets
voted out or just like just gets clown
down so hard that it's just like he's so
humiliating is there any celebrity that
hasn't been on it that you would like
love to see on Big Brother oh my god I
would love to see why like he'd never do
it George Clooney oh my god he would be
amazing it would be amazing I think he I
think you would win I think he'd be a
Derek like genius player sail through to
the end but yeah I don't I mean gosh I
really like I I don't know if there's a
celebrity that I wouldn't want to see on
it okay um especially we know we're just
fresh off of well kind of fresh off of
Celebrity Big Brother the first one here
right right right that was just awesome
that was pretty great Ross was pretty
impressive i Ross Marie like I loved if
the whole cast like Metta World Peace
team like it was some some like stuffed
animal or toy or something that he would
just carry around it wasn't or well I
was it it was oh my god both or balls on
every season big brother because he's
representative of big brother after dark
on pop that was so funny that he would
just walk around holding that thing all
day long I think that was the cutest and
he was legitimately losing and I'm it
felt like he was sitting by himself
talking to the cameras in the corner I
loved I loved it so much and I really
think like celebrity bebe was made when
he was he was talking to God it was a
Kishin [ __ ] I don't I don't I don't
exactly remember but it was like
essentially his Alliance early on in the
game and they were like who did you vote
for and he was like I voted to keep
sones
I voted to keep so-and-so and they were
like no when you go in there and say
their name you're voting to evict them
and he was just like no idea what he was
signing up for
oh it was beautiful I feel like he
thought he was signing up for like a
reality show to live in a nice house and
he had no idea how the game my god but
he absolutely but he truly he truly
nailed it he's really nailed it and also
my favorite was like Shannon Elizabeth
was on it and they were buddies and some
and she got voted off earlier than him
and he was doing this exit interview
with Julie and Julie was like who do you
think's going to take this and he was
like Shannon that season made me want to
wear like under eye debuggers I felt
like every woman on the show every scene
one of them's got a pair of these under
eye things on oh yeah those are cool
yeah I felt the exact same way I was
like I have to get some I should care
more about my eyes hey no do you ever
try them yeah they are very good they're
very good they're very soothing how do
you not get them in the actual I don't
know they seem to wear them effortless
any time I wear them and they just slime
down my face and it doesn't work out
same but are there any other reality
shows that you're as obsessed with or
like slightly less obsessed with me yeah
I mean I'm I'm just a fool for Bravo
Vanderpump
have you gone to Vanderpump have you
gone to the restaurant and gonna serve
yes I've been to serve I've been you see
any of them there I yes we were my safe
space I've also been to sir I've been to
pump
I haven't been to Tom Shean yeah it's on
the to-do list you know that's the place
to go cuz they got those frozen shots oh
yeah they've been working hard on it and
the food and Alex I have seen some of
them there but being this shy freak dork
that's so scared of everyone I was just
like oh my god Lala just walked in like
it was it was really cool I think the
Tom's might have been outside by valet
it was it was really great but I think
it is like as like a Vanderpump superfan
it is
an art of picking what night of the week
you go to have optimum people cast yeah
I feel like they must have contracts
absolutely where they can drink for free
there if they show up to hang out and
that they're obligated to like work
quote-unquote like once a month
oh yeah cuz I feel like there's no way
that they're just hanging out there I
would I would hope not these are super
stars let me walk amongst us seriously
they really do and like I mean they're
doing their own successful businesses
like yeah like props to them for even
making it in one day a week yeah god
bless Amer great there I'm glad that
you're obsessed with that show
I am also obsessed with that show it's
coming back and I also go and I watch
all their snapchats and like Instagram
stories to see if they're like really
friends in life and they are they seem
to really support each other now oh I'm
all over those instagrams they're so
good they're so good okay what is maybe
the least useful constructive criticism
that you've ever received oh my god
least useful constructive criticism I
would say like as so I try I tried very
hard to do improv and sketch comedy in
Chicago and I just loved it I grew up
seeing the shows only oh it's so cool
but again like I'm this painfully shy
like super anxious like just holding it
all in weirdo freak so it was like oh I
would almost barf before any like stupid
little improv show I'd be like oh god
like really got to make this work can't
let down the team that kind of thing
and you know sometimes you know I could
get out there and sometimes my anxiety
and like fear and terror would you know
keep me back and I would not be in as
much of the show so I'd say like the
least constructive criticism would be
fel other people that I knew at the
theater coming up to me and being like
we just it's just we just would look
it's just it would just be so great if
you got out there more it's like you
think [ __ ]
I do too but you have no God you don't
know anything in my brain you know like
there's about 70 people up there telling
me to shut up and leave and no one will
notice if you go change your name and
love to Evanston right you like gave up
trying to do improv it's like you just
that like this job like oh like come on
buddy speak up jab jab it's like I think
I'm driving down exactly yeah it's like
you didn't think that was cool I was in
like one and a half I was gonna ask
about doing improv and sketch comedy are
there any particular like weird or like
worst show scenarios that happen oh my I
when I was doing the improv in New York
the worst one was this new cool bar and
Williamsburg open and they asked us like
one of our teammates knew the owner and
he wasn't coming to a show and we
started on this stage and the they
didn't even turn their music off that
was playing and no one in the bar looked
at us he couldn't hear anything it was
just 20 minutes of screaming in to avoid
it was so bad that is a beautiful like
truly truly tragic and I just I was so
bummed because there's a cool bar that I
wanted to be able to go back to and I
was like I can't go never come back here
100% yes like so many of those
experiences just like really bad stuff
um I know I did
improv at like a kind of summer stocky
Improv Theater and Maine okay yeah was
such an experience so so fun so crazy
but I remember one night I think we did
like one night we did maybe like a
two-hour short form show so soon like
two hours of like zippy to do like I'm
gonna sing this line like just imagine
two hours of that for two people oh my
for two people and is it they you know
we obviously like we level we do but we
but also like these people came and they
drove out and they're like we can't send
them home without a show so we thought
we would give them this great you know
the regular show what we do whenever how
yeah but it turns out like comedy
doesn't work like that like you need
other people to be laughing like you
can't count on like Martha and Bob to
like get you on everyone they're tired
they don't want this so that's like one
of my top I'll never I'll never forget
that I toured for a while with second
city with like the best people and most
women were the best people and but no
truly that the people I got to act with
I got jacked with so my best friends and
we would we would go around the country
doing these shows I mean those were like
two hour-long sketch and improv just
like extravagance as they were they were
epic and we do a third act of improv and
we traveled somewhere maybe at the very
tip of Wisconsin okay and not one laugh
for over two hours yeah and we were so
shamed that I was like guys should we
just drive back to Chicago tonight like
I don't know anything I can stay at
Howard Johnson at night I feel like such
a piece of [ __ ] oh my god how many
people were there
that was a packed auditorium grace it
was it was completely full which was
really exciting at the start yeah why
how did that happen you know I don't
know I don't know if it was the wrong
tone or the wrong flavor I guess you
know second city is you know an amazing
you know it has this great history you
know kind of calm you know politically
you know you know just trying to you
know stay current maybe we weren't in
line with their values we were actually
we weren't in line with their values
most of the time but but yeah I think I
just think you know maybe or you know
what maybe the five of us were just like
legit not good that night not a single
Chuck that is devastating especially
when like between these things that are
bombing they're these like just a banger
needle drops that are like oh yeah
ah this is making it worse this is bad
this is bad so we did drive back to
Chicago that night yeah oh god that is
yeah that's brutal supposing the
memories you try to just keep okay if
you were gonna be on the show my strange
addiction yeah what do you think your
strange addiction would be oh my god my
strange addiction yeah it's tough
how I mean this is like kind of flame
okay chocolate um oh you know I try my
best but I can't really go to sleep
without having just oh I mean I any kind
you think you have I you know from from
her she's all the way to there like
those truffles like I'm there I'm ready
for it I guess that's not really a
strange addiction I guess we're all kind
of chocoholics like Kathy and all this
all that yeah yeah exactly um but if you
can't fall asleep without it then that
could be strange it should be strange so
you made the cut ha ha how long have you
lived in LA no I have lived in LA I'm
coming up on my 5-year anniversary I've
years okay yeah so what kind of advice
would you give to someone that is moving
here or to yourself five years ago
before you got here oh my gosh um great
that's a really great question
my advice is gonna sound really really
stupid as hell but it's really true my
advice has just come I feel like it's
like coming from Chicago in New York
like we all you know sometimes we get
scared like am I ready like do I have
enough under my belt here to go there
and be somebody or do something and I
think that like those are all great
questions but I think that it's really
honestly all a crapshoot and you can do
what you're doing there here if you feel
like drawn to here because of these
wonderful opportunities additions and
stuff like there's so much going on and
like obviously it's the entertainment
capital
well yes you should be here so my advice
to anyone moving out here is like don't
don't fret yeah come on through just try
just try it and you can you can leave
you know I've had plenty of friends you
know one of my best friends was like not
I I can't I don't I do not like it and
that's okay okay yeah absolutely so I
say like come on out and also like be
ready to meet some really nice people
like there's this like this thought that
like oh la people some nice tan Maine
actually like some some of the nicest
people I've met have been out here and
it's been really lovely so I think like
push those misconceptions to the side
and come on come on through that's
really great advice I think people just
sometimes need an extra push absolutely
I need to know that it's not the end of
the world yeah it doesn't work out yeah
do you have like a backup because
sometimes in my head I have a back-up
plan that I'm like this is when I run
into the wind and we see what happens
and I joke a lot about becoming a WWE
Superstar because I know you can and I
just want to I want to be your manager
in the rain is what would be really fun
yeah I have a whole character I have to
come up with the name but basically she
always has a hangover and she comes out
just so I'm Kim and it's basically her
walk down from backstage is a walk of
shame type of scenario dirty sweatpants
and be perfect you just have to can you
get into NXT now because like that is so
funny I really think about it but what
would be your bag my bag a plan if I
mean a one being your Paul Heyman you
know what I really I think about it a
lot because like I'm constantly at every
second of every day prepared to fail
100% so I you know my backup plan I
guess like I've held such high jobs you
know pizza places I worked at homemade
Pizza Kitchen which is now shut down in
Chicago you basically like Bill
like a dough it's just a raw pizza and
then you bake it at home like you like
you [ __ ] did something no you didn't
you just spent $26 on a raw piece of
[ __ ] joke's on you but I worked there
for a while I've been a nanny I you know
I worked at Victoria's Secret I
shouldn't be saying these names on
you're trying to get brand deals yeah I
am ready oh my god and semi-annual sale
how long did you work Oh God
I worked there yeah I worked there for
quite a while maybe about a year until I
found I thought I hadn't really made it
when I got a management opportunity in
retail and I was like Victoria Vicki
Vicki I'm not sure to go sell purses
which I Darren did that forever but I
worked at Victoria's Secret for about a
year in Chicago I met some of the most
amazing like the woman I worked with
where the [ __ ] best funniest people
amazing ever but you know it's like it's
a it's a store where you can working
there you can run into some like scary
that's or interesting things I was gonna
say I'm sure it runs the gamut who's
walking through the door and they're
coming in there and why they're coming
in oh my god I owe Mike have you ever
had to ask anyone to leave you know I
again going back to being shy I never
had the balls to like one time like like
I I saw this woman came in with like a
baby and like the baby just had like two
little fistfuls of like lip glosses and
I was like I couldn't like it was just
like if you need the like lip gloss I
just couldn't you know yeah you know
what can you do loss prevention I try my
best I had like one time one of my
comedy front my Chicago comedy friends
his girlfriend came in was like hey how
are you doing and I'm pretty sure she's
stole a lot of [ __ ] but what what like I
don't know like what I could you know
what is you're not making money on them
by
no I was barely making enough to pay my
cell phone bill if it's a Victoria's
Secret so it's the you know it's it's
hard it's it's hard I'm sure you've seen
the entire spectrum of the male
emotional response to Victoria's Secret
oh my god and I'm sure you've seen
plenty of like lingers oh the lingers
yeah yeah did you get a lot of dudes
just coming in by themselves not knowing
or just coming in kind of pervy yeah Oh
with it without a doubt without a doubt
more often than not if you were if you
were coming in by yourself you were
usually pervy I remember this one
gentleman who came in I was like oh what
a sweet older gentleman like this will
be nice this is great yeah he came in
this really long like trench coat yeah
and I was like hey sir like you know I
big this is gonna be sweet he's getting
some his wife like this is lovely
hey what do you recommend for my niece I
was like oh my and but then I was like
can I give him the benefit of the doubt
he's just trying to be cool he wants to
be the cool guy he it's either you want
to be the cool uncle and you're sweet
and you're well-meaning which I'm sure I
give you the credit for that or on the
other and you you're up to some nasty
porn [ __ ] I'm like have you been talking
like pornhub or like what the other
mainstream ones I'm talking about like
the ones you go to Google and you dig
deep for like this guy's on that website
so there is a lot of stuff like that
like also calls more less dark than that
would be this example of this guy or a
group of guys that would call up and
they would just keep you on the phone
for as long as they could and they'd be
like do you like yeah we got a ton like
come on and see him it's like wait wait
what colors yeah yeah I was I I was
ignorant to the first few calls and I
would stay on that phone forever and
then like one of my girlfriend's is like
what are you doing like there and I was
like oh that's what they're doing and
then like I just couldn't help myself
the rest of the call I'd still take the
calls
I'd be like you don't want to talk to
flip back I like patch them through up
here like I'll take them
don't mind you're an A+ employee that's
what I felt I don't know I don't I don't
know you know if I that's so so great
okay we're taking another quick break
when we get back we have a bunch of
Twitter questions for you some that are
really fun so we'll be right back whoa
what's up grace I'm excited because this
episode of not too deep is sponsored by
cafe monster oh yes because for many of
us the day doesn't start until we get
that morning energy boost let me guess
you're talking about coffee that's right
I am talking about coffee and now
there's a new way to enjoy your daily
cup of joe thanks to cafe monster let me
tell you it's available in vanilla mocha
and salted caramel cafe monster is
shaking up they're ready to drink coffee
category with indulgent gourmet coffee
that is only 190 calories not to mention
with a hundred and fifty milligrams of
caffeine from coffee beans B vitamins
and coffee fruit extract cafe monster
offers a simplified energy blend that
contains a third less sugar than the
leading national brand and in fact it's
100 fewer calories per bottle than the
competition but you'd never know it by
tasting it instead you get all the same
feel and flavor as your local coffee
house you don't the wait in line which
is perfect
I hate inter personal experiences so
this is absolutely exceptional for me
and also the fact that their mocha
tastes exactly like chocolate milk is an
added bonus yes that is absolutely
delicious what's your favorite Jack I
become a mocha person myself I used I
used to like the salted caramel yeah
that's a good thing as they're all
delicious so it can change day to day it
can but I've gotten really maybe because
it's getting a little colder the mocha
is just like that's comforting
chocolatey feeling yeah you know and you
know what they always say Oh tell me
cafe monster chill it down shake it up
enjoy that classic colloquial support
for today's show comes from crave
gourmet jerky made with tender gourmet
cuts of meat and elevated yet simple
ingredients crave jerky is a great
source of protein that's low in fat
Lewton free and contains all natural
ingredients oh not to mention the range
of flavors is bold and imaginative from
sweet and tangy to savory and spicy so
what's your favorite because they've got
some interesting flavors they have so
many flavors I've said it before I'll
say it again the sweet Chipotle beef is
my favorite it's got the perfect balance
of sweet and savory it's what I look for
all hours of the day yeah that one's
really good they also have black cherry
barbecue pork which is just a very
interesting flavor but my favorite
actually is the chili lime beef oh is it
really my beef guy mm yeah so you guys
can try one of craves bold tender
flavors like chili lime beef or sweet
chipotle beef thank you like cherry
barbecue pork by going to crave jerky
calm that's crave with a k KR a ve je r
KY dot-com get 20% off when you use the
code grace you're AC e that's crave
jerky comm offer code grace this episode
of not too deep is brought to you by get
ready frisky britches frisky
britches it's changing the way women
shop for underwear no more emergency
runs to the store on laundry day no more
digging through piles of underwear to
find something that you like instead
frisky britches offers a selection of
high quality panties in a variety of
styles colors materials and patterns
simply choose your style and size and
you'll get two brand-name colorful and
comfy underwear sent straight to your
door every month it is the perfect gift
for yourself or your friends and will
make a great stocking stuffer during the
holiday season and I can attest they are
comfortable they are cute they are
high-quality and they are delivered
regularly you never know what life is
going to throw at you so might as well
depend on you know your frisky Britch
everyone's got one
frisky britches has your back literally
when it comes to feeling your best
starting from the moment you put on your
britches so go to shop
frisky britches calm to get started and
as a special deal for you our beautiful
listeners you'll get 20% off your first
month which is you know regularly priced
at $14 using code grace grac e that's
shop frisky britches
komm offer code grace for 20% off your
first month okay Kate before we get into
these Twitter questions I'm gonna ask
you the two questions I ask every guest
that's on the podcast and the first is
who alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti act oh my gosh cold
spaghetti alive or dead or fictitious
fictitious Hitler okay yeah fair answer
I'd I would love to see that thing great
okay the other question is to tell us
your worst pants [ __ ] story or close
call but you can only use three words or
three small phrases so mine is college
jogging front yeah it's I almost had a
new one the other day three words or
small phrases rare steak car oh wow yeah
that's a beautiful spoken thank you also
to add I didn't have a washer and dryer
where I was living so I had to go to the
laundromat after that oh wow extra just
layers of shame you survived
okay now we have some Twitter questions
for you someone asked you and someone
are stuck on an island who is that
someone who who is that someone
yeah me and someone are stuck on an
island who is that someone
Wow I mean can I say Miguel but like yes
but also his fiance is there okay what's
her name
I think it's nazaneen-e one he calls her
Jan's nasty she's awesome she's like
she's she also a musician um she has
been a singer she does sing she acts she
does it out she's this drop-dead
gorgeous model does her own yeah she's
really cool and she also like is has a I
don't know what we call this now but she
has a lot of like really truly actually
and
raishin 'l like insights and things that
she posts on Instagram and in her
stories and it she's just like the dream
yeah yeah absolutely sounds like
everything she does is Leslie Wonder it
truly is that so I guess I cheated that
would be two people you can bring a bomb
can i yeah there's no rules
someone's to know what your favorite
childhood memory is Wow yeah that's
that's a tough one or I would say your
favorite like I Oh memory oh that's so
sweet
I'll do I'll do childhood I my favorite
childhood memories is seeing Little
Richard live was like one of my first
concerts and my mom took me to see him
at Ravinia which is we lived in the city
but Rivini I was like many suburbs north
where where the rich people stay it's
this like outdoor amphitheater it's it's
lovely and yeah my mom took me to see
Little Richard and she got in on the
tickets early so we were like second row
Wow yeah and he just kept drinking like
I mean I saw that like it was like what
two hours show and it was epic I mean
he's amazing but um he just kept
drinking Gatorade he had like eight to
12 Gatorade and he was like I just need
more of my juice one well man wow that's
the secret
yeah is really young maybe a wow what a
cool mom to bring you to a show like
that my parents really cool is for sure
awesome okay someone's to know if you
could eat any typically inedible object
what would you eat and why um if I could
eat anytime wow I'm gonna think about
what my answer to this would be great
question um maybe a couch yeah baby I
don't know I think about it more but
maybe a couch that was my first thing
that came to mind I was kind of led that
way I don't know why like I don't know
if it's cause like fruit leathers and
you going to like upholstery I don't
know like
yeah how it should be great CD o CD
chomping on his great someone wants to
know is there a scene you can remember
filming on teachers that was the most
hard to film without breaking out and
laughter oh my god did you guys were you
improvising on set a lot with each other
whenever we had time we definitely would
which is always so fun
gosh where I didn't work I was hard to
laugh I mean I'm so scared when we're
doing it that I'm going to ruin the day
for everyone
oh yeah that is it I mean because
there's so many other factors yeah and
so many other people that are like
depending on the schedule yeah sticking
to plan absolutely so that that fear
usually keeps me keeps me pretty
horrified and grounded but gosh I've
seen where it's sorry was there a cast
member that was most notorious for
breaking I would definitely say the cast
member most notorious for breaking and
in greatly encouraging the breaking of
others would be the wonderful Tim Bagley
who plays principal appears and like
obviously is is the funniest living
human but would would at times deliver a
line or if he had spaced on the line the
the search for that line was so epically
hilarious so I yeah I definitely say he
was the one who was making us all of us
break whatever yeah what a guy that's a
little nicest guy too
oh yeah yeah how was the casting process
for that cuz you guys brought in a lot
of like amazing comedian oh my god so
cool so cool we had a great um so much
props to our casting directors I'm
sherry Hernandez like just brought in
like the coolest Scott like because you
know we're all huge comedy fans so like
yeah that's like oh like would so-and-so
like would they even like really email
about this show
so cool so that can like the casting
process was kind of like surreal in the
sense that like you know we were coming
from Chicago having shot a webseries and
we had amazing amazing people in that
that we looked up to and then coming out
here and the people that sherry would be
able to bring to us we're I mean it was
it was crazy like meeting your comedy
heroes every day like Andy Daly yeah
just Ian Roberts who was our showrunner
also do ya funny like I mean just meet
him sitting down with him when we did
when we were like trying to find a show
I mean it was the whole yeah crazy so
lucky have you had a sincere fangirl
moment on set oh my god we're just in LA
in general
definitely I yeah I again like I love
them I'm impressed by all the
celebrities I will never say anything
but I geeked out from you know seen
Julie Andrews at my agents office like
we were doing some like we were I think
we were gonna actually about to screen
the pilot Oh back in the day and I was
waiting in the wrong spot and Julie
Andrews was there and I was like well
well that's like really [ __ ] and
saying yeah and then seeing like you
know from that to like seeing like the
that the Nolan twins from Big Brother
few years ago like seeing them at like
mess hall and low cos I'm like oh my god
I'm starstruck every day in last oh I
know it's so weird it's so weird seeing
them be real people oh my god yeah
insane okay someone wants to know least
favorite fruit least favorite fruit yeah
oh gosh my least favorite fruit would
probably they used to be my favorite but
now I'm in a weird face kumquats okay so
like what's up I can't say I've ever had
one try one I need to know anything
I don't know yes to be good I think they
just freak me out a little bit those in
Kiwis like Kiwis freak me out
yeah yeah these Kiwis are a make or
break situation they're either really
good or slimy and yeah that's a texture
thing oh yeah okay last question someone
to know if you can star in any horror
universe which would it be and why any
horror universe or universe yeah are you
a horror fan yes I'd say like I'm an
ignorant horror fan like I'm like oh I
love that I'd love to watch that but
like I don't know like like the great
horror films I probably am not so
well-versed in but I would say that I
would really love to like being a
Chicago kid I would love to if they
redid Candyman you have never seen it oh
it's really good and it's also like so
eighties Chicago can demand or I'm Chuck
have you seen any of the Chucky a little
bit I'm a giant [ __ ] yeah I do not
watch a lot of scary movies I was
terrified as a kid about Jurassic Park
really kind of set the tone that that's
what I'm scared of
and having nightmares about
Tyrannosaurus Rex coming to my window I
don't think I can handle the other one
right on right on
yeah right on well when if you ever are
feeling risky
Candyman are Chucky's because they're
both there in a way funnier than scary
but also pretty scary I'll have to check
them out okay thank you for your making
time I'm so pumped that you got to come
be here every guest that makes time for
being on not too deep we give them a
little token of our appreciation it's a
customized fortune cookie oh my gosh jag
has it right here and you can feel free
to open it of course thank you so much
for having me crazy yes so not like such
a obviously no big whoa I'm really
really excited oh my god it is really
long
a ghost flew out just as you open this
cookie it says thanks but also might
follow you around for a bit because you
seen
how that goes also where can people find
you online or find out what you're
working on and they don't already know
that's such a nice question
you can I do have a Twitter account but
I usually leave that dormant for once in
a blue moon but I Kate Friedman and
really I'm on instagram at Kate Friedman
CA te awesome guys go check out if you
haven't she is wildly hilarious oh so
sweet and again thanks Kate thanks for
having me of course we'll see you guys
next time on another episode of not to
tape goodbye - deep deep deep deep cafe
Monster is shaking up the ready to drink
coffee category with indulgent gourmet
coffee that's only 190 calories
available in vanilla mocha and salted
caramel they have a hundred fifty
milligrams of caffeine from coffee beans
B vitamins and coffee fruit extract in
every bottle cafe monster offers a
simplified energy blend that contains a
third less sugar than a leading national
brand but you still get the feel and
flavor of your local coffee house
without having to wait in the line and
let me tell you guys try the mocha
because it really does taste like
delicious delicious chocolate kaby
monster chill it down shake it up enjoy
not too deep as a production of grace
helbig incorporated a producer and
directed by Jack Fairy producer and
editor
Melissa demons writing by Diane King
production assistants by Audriana Monte
agudo post-production sound by Chris
Henry and an extra special thanks to
Flula for the theme music
[Music]